[Music]
how do i stop scrolling through facebook
and youtube all day
question
mark all this says
that's the entirety of the email
i'll read it again for those of you who
are driving
how do i stop i don't know why
you're driving that it's kind of funny
how do i stop scrolling through facebook
and youtube all day
well wendy you've come to the right
place i'm not very smart on a lot of
things but i got your back on this one
i'm going to teach you a hack
um i love hacks
hacks are so stupid there's no such
thing but i'm gonna i got one i got one
um
you consume facebook in youtube
um through these magical devices
they have screens on them they're either
smart phones
tablets ipads tvs
um anything
probably some glasses i don't know you
could probably implant it into your head
but they're consumed on electronic
devices and i did not know this existed
it's fantastic but on all electronic
devices
hold your hold your hats ladies and
gentlemen
there's an off button
and you can just push the crap out of it
and the whole thing just goes
and turns off
and then no more facebook and no more
youtube
it just stops it stops that's life hacks
uh 101 with dr d here and here's the
here's the
here's the the the real truth here
we scroll facebook and youtube because
we're freaking lonely
and we scroll facebook and youtube
because
um we don't like the the worlds we've
built for ourselves or we're bored or
we're spacing out or we're trying to
numb or we're trying to distract
and i am the worst
my crack is instagram i'll just sit
there and scroll forever
how do you stop scrolling build a life
worth living
you want to know how to get off the
internet how to stop spending all your
days on social media
build yourself a life worth living
that makes going to a screen seem like
an absurd waste of your time because
your real life is being lived over here
number of couples i talk to that sit on
the couch and just scroll instagram he's
on espn.com and she's on pinterest and
you know what they could be doing it
they could be doing it right there and
they're not they're just scrolling
they're just scrolling biologically
that's insane that's matt what are we
doing
are people just stand in line surrounded
by a whole bunch of other people and
they just look at their phones you know
what you could be doing
hang with me here you could go hey
what's up how's it going
yesterday i was walking to the store and
this guy was buying like a 20 bag a 30
pack of beer and he dropped it and it
exploded
and it was incredible and his reaction
was he started dying laughing and then i
started laughing and then everybody
started laughing and then they came over
and helped him clean up his beer and he
was covered in it and i made some jokes
he made some jokes it was amazing and if
i had been scrolling on some sort of
stupid platform i would have missed all
of it
i would have candy crushed my way
out of a guy dropping a case of beer on
himself it was phenomenal and then he
had the greatest reaction ever because
he's just started die laughing it made
my heart so big
build a life worth living
for most of us that means engaging in
relationships that are hard that means
asking ourselves is this the place i'm
gonna work for the rest of my freaking
life
it's asking ourselves did this t-shirt
really make me feel better about myself
or this new guitar or this new gun or
this new car or this bigger house or
this new person i'm texting even though
i'm married to somebody else is it
actually created no it's not
it's taking a mess and making it more
chaotic
how do i stop scrolling through facebook
and youtube all day
build a life worth living
be a person other people want to be
around
invite people into your life
do
something different